[Musique]
un film dans lequel vous aimeriez vivre
pire middle west side story pour la
norme sans hésiter trop ça ou un pixar
mais plutôt à side story
pourquoi ah bah ouais ça history je
pense est évident bon déjà les années 60
aux etats unis a quand même une
nostalgie de plein de choses et puis
c'est tellement festif tellement
magnifique de pouvoir chanter son nom
vous seriez de quelques rats c'est une
bonne question vous savez peut-être
maria cela dit je crois que j'aurais
maria à la whey doublé réfléchi oui
c'est sûr je connais rien le film qui
vous a donné envie de faire du cinéma
moi c'est plus le théâtre qui m'a amené
au cinéma vraiment souvent les
journalistes me demandent où les gens
même c'est vraiment la curiosité de le
premier film la scène l'acteur vraiment
moi c'est un peu moins glamour
finalement c'est et en même temps c'est
quelque chose de très important c'est
vraiment les profs les bons professeurs
de théâtre les bons pédagogues qui
savent tu te dire que c'est possible que
c'est envisageable pour aller chercher
quoi justement au cinéma que vous ne
trouviez pas dans le théâtre
je trouvais tout dans le théâtre mais
j'étais curieux du cinéma qui est un art
tellement jeune par rapport au théâtre
qui encore en pleine invention en
constante évolution le théâtre aussi
mais il ya quelque chose de très près de
très nouveau dans le cinéma par rapport
au théâtre et puis les artifices quoi la
puissance de l'artifice mis au service
d'une histoire le gros plan la voix off
le ralenti voilà plein de choses qu'on
peut pas faire au théâtre et qui sont
quand même des outils extraordinaires
quoi vraiment le pitch du film que vous
rêveriez de réaliser les gains possibles
à produire aujourd'hui il ya plein de
films qui sont plus en plus dure à
produire donc j'ai presque envie de dire
un film normal déjà c'est dur à produire
donc mais peut-être moi j'aimerais bien
faire un film
en faisant moi même mes cascades c'est
un truc qui m'excite ah c'est vrai ouais
hein avec un bon scénario et tout mais
quand même l'idée d'un investissement
physique à 200% belle bourde ou ouais
ouais ouais ouais j'ai un peu cette
nostalgie là des fois sur des sur des
choses et puis les gens ont toujours
vachement l'admiration tu vas te disais
à tom cruise il faut sur gasquet
lui-même
moi si je disais un producteur j'ai lu
le film les cascades c'est moi il va me
rire au nez parce que c'est pour les
assurances et tous ces morts donc elle
conseille ce que vous donneriez un
acteur qui débute qui fit il tout
premier pas aujourd'hui moi je me sens
tellement d'enjeux l'espère début de
carrière et jeune carrière que j'ai
vraiment du mal à prodiguer des conseils
pour des gens d'autant encore une fois
que je trouve qu'être pédagogue savoir
donner les bons conseils aux bonnes
personnes et y est ouais parce que en
fait maintenant ce genre plus moyen truc
qui me rend dingue c'est une espèce de
conseils généraliser à tout le monde
avec les réseaux sociaux on a vachement
salle et les phrases un peu inspirante
le côté sois toi-même ne change pas mais
ne dit que tu dises à hitler c'est une
catastrophe
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc il faut
surtout pas il faut surtout de changer
disait oui la changer il ya des gens il
faut leur dire tu vois le côté sois toi
même tu me fait très peur en fait les le
côté t'as pas changé quand on me dit ça
lundi m6 forcément j'ai rencontré des
gens qui m'ont changé dans pour le
meilleur parfois je sais pas la vie est
une constante évolution des espèces de
trucs donc les conseils vraiment que le
dire à tout le monde
il faut faire ça il faut faire ça non de
mon expérience à moi ce qui moi m'a
servi en tout cas c'est de ne pas avoir
peur du ridicule ça c'est un truc qui
m'a libéré beaucoup de choses de me dire
que le ridicule flirte souvent avec le
génial quoi à bosser ne nous on peut
vous dire vers le 4g vient d'où si le
cinéma peut pas changer le monde on est
tous d'accord avec ça qu'est ce qui peut
changer
on est tous d'accord avec le fait que ça
ne peut pas changer le monde a découlé
une diane au contraire à un peu quand
même vraiment j'espère j'espère va pas
le monde d'un coup mais un parent
peut-être les gens peu à peu ça peut
changer quand même le regard des gens
ouais je pense qu'il ya vraiment
quand j'arrive pas à convaincre
quelqu'un dans une conversation souvent
je me dis rapide j'ai envie de produire
un film juste pour le persuader que j'ai
raison quoi bien dîné le film raisons
qui vous a fait le plus de bien
je pense que c'est get out
ouais diatta route qui est un film que
j'ai adoré vraiment j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait un déjà un mélange des genres des
styles qui était complique il s'en fout
quoi qui s'affranchit de tout ça c'est
un film qui fait du bien
ouais moi ça m'a fait et je trouvais ça
très jouissif très physique très
didactique de la comédie du film
d'horreur du film politique de ces tout
est mélangé tout fonctionne pour moi je
trouve que j'ai trouvé ça vraiment très
moderne
je me tourne jamais accueilli parce
qu'il avait descendu get out ici
philippe pur film de genre et en même
temps avec un vrai discours politique
c'est exactement ce qu'on aime dans
l'histoire du cinéma de genre
c'est-à-dire s'emparer de code pour
aller plus loin et le field est
totalement pédagogique complètement
complètement c'est une réussite totale
et à chaque fois je me dis quoi vraiment
proposer ça un producteur faut y aller
quand même quoi parce que tu lis le
scénario je pense que halluciné et à
dire baloga et sous lsd il m'envoie
sonar ça n'est pas possible il ya un tel
mélange de choses et et ça marche
extrêmement bien vous auriez dit oui
vous mais justement ça en disant ça
c'est que je me dis que ça se trouve
bon il se trouve que je connaissais
jordan fils parce que je il ya un duo de
comédies que j'adore aux états unis qui
s'appelle qu'à une pile avec un autre
acolyte à lui où ils sont
extraordinaires
donc j'aurais dit oui à sa proposition
là parce que je le connais mais
quelqu'un que je connais pas avec un
scénario aussi dingue bas il faut y
aller on voit quand même mais moi je dis
oui est-ce que vous applaudissent
maintenant le métier formidable